et on en vient au chapitre à des
violences policières avec les suites
notamment de la sphère gabriel il ya une
enquête a été ouverte sur l'arrestation
du jeune homme âgé de 14 ans qui accuse
des policiers de l'avoir frappée et
gravement blessé au visage lors de son
interpellation à bondy en
seine-saint-denis
l adolescent a été arrêté dans la nuit
du 25 au 26 mai dernier alors qu'il
tentait de voler un scooter
l'autorité a été saisie au titre de la
défense des droits de l'enfant et du
contrôle de la déontologie des forces de
sécurité à le parquet de bobigny de son
côté a déjà ouvert une enquête confiée à
l'igpn la police des polices
l'avocat du jeune gabriel de man lui la
suspension avec des quatre policiers mis
en cause ont l'écoutent
je demande que gabriel soit
officiellement reconnue ans a guidé des
victimes et que les policiers évidemment
soin d'avoir traduit devant un tribunal
et que leurs responsabilités ensuite
soit soir aux lesparrains par le
tribunal compétent
mais ça ce sera dans le temps de l'
enquête judiciaire chose qui ne peut pas
se passer avant trois quatre cinq mois
et je ne cesse de le dire
c'est heureux c'est heureux parce qu'il
nous faut une bonne justice iphone os x
qui prenne son temps et une justice qui
vérifie évidemment les arguments de
chacun
vu la gravité des faits qui ont été
commis sur gabriel ça n'est absolument
pas une justice expéditive que je
demande en revanche dans la tente
évidemment de ce travail qui doit se
dérouler en toute sérénité de la barre
d'abord du procureur de la république et
ensuite des magistrats du siège qui
seront saisis de ce dossier
il me paraît absolument inévitable
qu'une suspension administrative soient
prises afin que ces policiers qui sont
rendus compte de rendu coupable de
violences aussi grave sur 7 à 30 14 ans
ne puisse pas continuer à exercer leur
fonction comme si de rien n'était
continuer à maintenir l'ordre et la paix
dans la dans cette ville de bondy comme
si de rien n'était alors même qu' il y a
je crois des soupçons pour reprendre
l'expression de notre miss de
l'intérieur qui sont plus que solide
dans le cadre de la sphère de gabriel